l'autoroute à 10 en Touren a connu en
octobre une activité pas banale après le
camion incandescent en début de mois le
semi-remorque chargé de moutons des 525
moutons une centaine a survécu et aucun
Novin n'a été percuté sur l'autoroute
donc pas de surraaccident l'un des
risques majeurs quand des animaux se
retrouvent dans la nature un premier
temps les secourses sont arrivés et ont
dû secourir le le conducteur euh qui a
été blessé euh et ensuite nous avons
donc
dû recolationner de toutes les brevies
et moutons qui étaient éparpillés dans
la nature de façon à les
contenir pour ne pas qu'elle saute sur
l'au bois d'autoroute le caractère
exceptionnel du chargement a ralenti le
trafic dans la nuit jusqu'en début
d'après-midi circulation sur une voie et
arrêt ponctuel pour les opérations comme
le relevage du semiremorque l'accident a
eu lieu à 2h du matin et les secours ont
quitté les lieux en début d'après-midi
il a fallu faire venir un autre un autre
camion et puis transborder ben le le
chargement voilà donc c'est pour la
c'est la raison pour laquelle ça été
c'est relativement long d'autre part il
faut aussi il a fallu procéder également
au relevage du camion par l'intermère
deux grues qui sont ici à côté de moi
45è des moutons sont morts dans
l'accident ceux qui ont survécu ont été
pris en charge par les pompiers c'est
ceux que nous avons transversé dans
l'autre remorque de secours un petit peu
plus d'une centaine les animaux en bonne
santé finiront là où le semianglais les
é à l'abattoir